but then yeah you've got these these
bits here right now what is this - this
will miss - - there's a shift that's
gonna happen now which way is it going
to go to the right are you sure to the
left should I get them - great
I could I could okay now hold on a
second before we settle this argument
okay
just post a minute before we settle this
alley because we will okay imagine if
this is not you arguing in a classroom
with your friend or you arguing with
your teacher or a textbook that's going
to give you the answer if it were just
you and your own brain right and like no
desmos alone or like a thing what would
you do to work out I know it's to the
left or to the right but which one would
it be how would you do that
what do you reckon Zach you again I'm
not looking for like I think the answer
is this I want to know how would you
check whether your answer is correct any
suggestions what did you say
I could substitute some values in that
might be handy right so for example if I
put in a value like say X equals what
would you like to pick I'm gonna go with
two you'll see why in a second right you
really could choose anything but to be
helped for us for a reason they'll
become very apparent right if I put two
into this what happens to this 2 minus 2
squared it gives you 0 right so you see
how I'm sort of expecting when x equals
0 normally you get 0 but now I'm saying
when x equals 2 that's all the way over
here right now you get y equals 0 like
so sorry that was not a little done it
does matter it's a rough graph ok I'm
getting to that I haven't I haven't
looked at that last bit yet I'm just
needing out where it's going left and
right by the way how do we know who's
left and right rather than say up and
down this thing here what's it attached
to this nice - it's attached to the X
which is which axis the horizontal axis
right so that's why I already left all
right
and by testing - and I saw all the Y
value I would get is 0 right that's what
I got that's true but I didn't get
negative - did I right when I put in
positive 2
I got an intercept
okay so this guy here would be - and
then there's the X - 2 4 squared right
ok so now I've got the last bit right
I've covered this and this it's a
parabola the last thing I've got is this
guy and it shifts us again it's not left
to right how did I know I've already
done the x axis and you could write this
another way that might make it a little
more obvious this is really y plus 1 is
this do you agree with that I added 1 to
both sides so do you see this one
doesn't touch the X at all it's really
mucking around with this guy
it's an up/down factor does that make
sense up or down remember we were
looking at this and we let - - is to the
left right but there's kind of this like
opposite effect right when that's a
minus sign I go to the right that's
positive right see this y plus 1 that's
a it looks positive but it's it's the
opposite it's going to go down and you
can again you can test the point to
verify this for yourself so I'm going to
take this guy and instead of going
through 2 comma 0 it's going to go
through 2 comma negative 1 so I'm gonna
sort of draw it down like that now if
Sean suggested testing out this value -
right the reason why I went with it is
because I knew because of the way this
was written this form tells me not just
random piece of information it tells me
the vertex do you see that there that's
the vertex that's the piece of
information that I know I want anyway
right so I'm gonna go for that because
I'm gonna have to label it anyway if I'd
picked some other point later on I have
to test to find this anyway ok so now
we'll draw this properly because mine
are all a terrible mess right he's a
proper big graph it needs to be bigger
in that direction
so do you remember this morning I
started to draw and then I was like oh I
got more information and I realized my
graph looks wrong I was like oh no I've
got to rub this out because my numbers
are no longer to scale okay I know where
the thanks all right I know where the
vertex is to comment negative one have
you look at even my rough drawing what
is the one other piece of information
that my graph requires the Y intercepts
we already established as no X
intercepts how do I find the y intercept
is it this guy we had this argument this
morning didn't we like is it just this
number on the end what form is this
written in performative render it's in
general form right it's ax square plus
BX plus C right so if I put in X equal
zero which is how to find the y
intercept into all of here what happens
to these guys they all become 0 I can
disregard them you just get left with
negative 5
ok so now that I know that I want to put
negative 5 in an appropriate spot on to
my set of actions I'm going to go
negative 1 2 3 4 5 there's negative 5
I'm going to go through that point ok
and now I can work out where
appropriately 2 comma negative 1 should
be because now I have like actual scale
and here I can use right so I'm going to
go 1 2 that means 2 comma negative 1 is
about there okay and in fact I'm going
to go ahead and even going to label it
like sir okay there are no x-intercepts
I've got the only intercept there so now
I can actually join this thing up
and I mean it's not the best you guys
should be using a ruler I'm not because
I don't have one but I'm pretty happy
otherwise with all the features that are
on there weight hanging miss Elise oh
yeah just over here where would be thank
you thank you right and you can see it I
haven't drawn it on but now let me put
it on this you can see yeah there's my
axis of symmetry right and by the way if
you wanted you could just double check -
be just negative 4 in this case on 2a
which is negative 2 in this case
negative 4 negative 2 is indeed 2 isn't
it which is what we verified before but
we use completing the square to get
there does that make sense this is
actually what we call vertex form of the
problem because when you look at it
you're like there's the vertex to
negative 1 that's the way I would read
it ok probably should label that
equation as well - x squared si plus 4 X
minus 5 e okay so we have now in our
tool box all these different ways to
look at this strain do you have a
question or I thought a great question
could you read it off there for me could
anyone read it off x equals 2 it's x
equals because it's what kind of line
it's vertical by the way I'm gonna
emphasize that because later on in this
course we're going to look at parabolas
that don't have
vertical lines of symmetry so we'll
leave that for another day but this for
now it's for now it's important it's x
equals 2 because it's up and down yeah
this axis and I can read that because it
goes through the vertex already worked
out